welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and birds-of-prey is the first major
comic book film that we're gonna get in
2020 and shockingly there's still a lot
we don't know about it other than it has
an additional title that is
fantabulously long but recently the film
has released a poster of Harley Quinn
and the other characters that's filled
with visual clues and easter eggs in
addition to a short trailer that played
kind of as a joke before it's chapter 2
and based on this stuff I got a solid
theory for what this movie might
actually be that might make your mind
feel like a mallet is smashing through
spoiler warning in case any of my
speculation for this movie ends up being
too accurate and it ruins your life and
for a breakdown of the movie central
plot the characters some Easter eggs
hidden in their costumes and props be
sure to check out my breakdown from
earlier this year ok first let's look at
this recent poster now the birds of prey
are a team of female DC figures Huntress
mary elizabeth winstead Black Canary
jurnee smollett Bell and Renee Montoya
Rosie Perez in this case they're joined
by Harley Quinn Margot Robbie reprising
her breakout role from Suicide Squad
this group will be attempting to rescue
Cassandra Cain Ellijay basco from the
grip of the crime organization led by
Black Mask
Ewan McGregor along with Victor Zsasz
Chris Messina but based on footage in
this poster design this whole story
seems like it will revolve around Harley
Quinn and her unique point of view each
of the other characters and hardly
herself are depicted as birds flapping
around her head kind of like a cartoon
character gets knocked over the head
which by the way is not what happens in
real life when you suffer a concussion
it starts not Birds and then you fall
asleep and it gets real warm and fiery
until the paramedics dragged you back in
a life now there was a similar cartoony
shot in the Deadpool movie if you
remember the reason I bring this up is
Robbie's Harley Quinn does seem to be
for DC films what did Poole has been for
the Fox Marvel Universe and soon to be
the MCU
in the trailer shown before in chapter 2
hardly totally breaks the fourth wall
talks to us she crosses him to a promo
for another movie that is totally a
Deadpool movie and also kind of a
stiched move so could we see a
birds-of-prey film with Harley Quinn as
a narrator and I'll do you one better
maybe even an unreliable narrator the
way Deadpool was you can't really trust
the story as he's telling it what if in
Harley's case the reality we see from
her is not objective reality but a
fantastical shade of reality colored by
Harley's rose-tinted mind there's Clues
all over the place for this theory
notice the tattoo on her neck mind over
mayhem could be another piece of
evidence that we're actually gonna see
this whole Cassandra Cain rescue mission
from inside Harley's colorful
fantabulous perspective which colors
even the darkest of moments as like a
party inside a robbing music video that
could be why we see Victor Zsasz as a
bleach hair douche instead of the
scarred for every victim murderer that
he normally is in the Batman comics and
why we don't see black masks wearing a
black mask deep black skull mask is the
primary iconic aspect of his appearance
but maybe in this case Harley's
delusional mind filters these hardened
criminals as the boys you'd see at a
club and it filters her own experience
to give her an insane amount of costume
changes and enable her to talk to and
winked at the audience and then maybe in
reality she's you know a mumbly mental
patient wearing a potato sack as
terrifying sadists like Victor Zsasz and
black mask old knives to her throat
another possible glue for this shifting
reality can be spotted in the charms
that Harley wears around her neck now in
some trailer footage for charms include
mods and ends across Universal female
symbol paperclip and a J for Joker
shaped hook which by the way is the
detail that I really love because as a
fish hook it reflects the way Joker cut
Harleen Quinzel and kept her on the hook
except now as a fish she's wriggled free
from that hook but also in other shots
and in the poster imagery there's
another significant charm included among
them a dog tag in the shape of a dog
bone with the name Bruce and perhaps his
just meant as a joke literally has a dog
named Bruce that she named after Bruce
Wayne who in her eyes could just be
another member of Gotham's both the
elite nothing more but it's worth
keeping in mind that in some version of
the Batman stories
Joker discovers Batman's secret identity
so maybe Harley knows that Batman is
Bruce Wayne now it's not totally clear
in the DC Cinematic Universe which DC
films connect to each other it's all a
bit vague but let's say that Joker
shared that bombshell with this Harley
this might be a reality in which batman
bruce wayne is dead and maybe now that
harley where's Bruce named around her
neck it's kind of like her serial killer
trophy take him down
but because that charm doesn't appear
and every time we see her maybe that
trophy
only exists in her own fantabulous
fantasy but an external reality
it ain't bare also there's just some
great design that goes in all this
notice the shapes that they worked into
of the film the letter B is the mask and
then there's an arrow from huntresses
crossbow between the eye and are there's
a diamond between the R and the D and
then a lip in the D a dagger it looks
like in the S a baseball bat and the O a
diamond in the P a mallet in the R and
brass knuckles in the e and then one of
my favorite details the music from this
trailer this track is called heads will
roll by the e is perhaps there's a
deeper connection here because check out
the tattoo on Harley's cheek it's a
heart now in my last breakdown I pointed
out Cassandra Kane's cast and how the
Queen of Spades the queen of clubs the
queen of diamonds and the Queen of
Hearts were all drawn on it I speculated
that those Queens could parallel the
four women
the Queen of Spades four Huntress who
uses a crossbow which is pointed like a
spade the queen of clubs for Renee
Montoya the queen of diamonds for Black
Canary who sings and seems to embrace
finery and the Queen of Hearts for
Harley but maybe even the Queen of
Hearts imagery is connected to the Queen
of Hearts from Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland heads will roll could apply
to what this Queen of Hearts plans to do
with that mallet smash smash smash so
perhaps we can view Harley Quinn as
Alice and a wonderland of her own mind
tumbling down the rabbit hole of
insanity and by rescuing this young girl
she frees herself and that could be the
emancipation of this title a former
criminal psychologist driven mad by a
clown inspired and mate now isolated
from the former object of her obsession
and now on a path of self-discovery a
freedom that she could achieve by saving
a young substitute of her own innocence
armchair psychoanalysis hey comment down
below with your thoughts on this hit
that like button subscribe to new rock
stars for breakdowns of everything you
love follow me on instagram and twitter
at whew boss thank you for watching bye
[Music]